[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español diversos países de américa
latina han desarrollado procesos
electorales procesos que seguirán hasta
el final de este año para intentar
comprender algunos de los factores que
inclinan el voto de los electores y el
porqué pueden cambiar de orientación
saludamos a distancia aclaran martínez
de toledano
profesora del imperial college london
coordinadora de estudios sobre
desigualdades del patrimonio del
laboratorio de las desigualdades
mundiales clara martínez ustedes
actualmente en madrid bienvenida a esta
escala en parís más clara martínez de
toledano es codirectora junto con amor y
gethin y thomas piketty de un libro que
lleva por título
rivas política legal y test social
fracturas políticas y desigualdades
sociales un vasto y ambicioso estudio
que se ha dedicado a estudiar la
experiencia en términos electorales de
más de 50 países entre 1948 y el 2020
clara martínez
este trabajo inédito
solo es por su dimensión sino porque
también han abarcado los cinco
continentes de donde surgió la idea de
este vasto esfuerzo
este proyecto colaborativo en el que han
colaborado más de 20 investigadores en
los distintos cinco continentes surge a
raíz de un artículo de investigación que
escribió thomas piketty en 2018 en el
que analiza la evolución del voto en
base a las variables socioeconómicas en
eeuu reino unido y francia y a pesar de
que estos tres países tienen una
economía un sistema político y un
sistema de bienestar diferente lo que
thomas piketty documenta es que la
evolución del voto por nivel de renta y
por nivel de educación ha sido muy
similar por lo que nos propuso a movilla
tan ya mí hacer este mismo análisis para
el resto de democracias occidentales y
no occidentales del mundo para las que
disponemos de este tipo de estadísticas
y nos lanzamos a ello y empezamos este
proyecto en el que llevamos trabajando
desde 2018 esta investigación como usted
lo señala ha recurrido a múltiples
variables para tratar de hacer una
lectura lo más precisa posible de las
elecciones tiene que ver con si es el
electorado de población rural o urbana
si son más estudiosos que tienen más
estudios y tienen más diplomas y tienen
más ingresos si son hombres o mujeres
por religiones por cultura
por idiosincrasia el nivel de ingresos y
el de estudios parece ser la constante
que determina en muchos casos la
orientación del voto de los estudios que
ustedes han analizado
si en efecto lo que encontramos es que
la evolución por perfil de voto y por
perfil de renta ha sido muy similar en
las democracias occidentales en los años
50 y 60 los menos educados y los
individuos de menor renta votaban en
mayor medida a partidos de izquierda a
partidos socialistas partidos
socialdemócratas partidos comunistas
mientras que en la actualidad lo que
observamos es que el voto a la izquierda
se asocia más en mayor medida a
individuos de mayor educación y de mayor
renta sin embargo lo que es interesante
es que este cambio en el voto se ha
producido sólo en términos de educación
pero no en términos de renta los
individuos de menor rentas siguen
votando en mayor medida a partidos de
izquierdas mientras que los individuos
de mayor renta siguen votando en mayor
medida a partidos de derecha como los
años 40 y 50
ferran martínez en los de entre los 50
países que ustedes han estudiado hay
varios de américa latina están 6
concretamente brasil costa rica
argentina chile colombia méxico perú
estos países no escapan a esta condición
este condicionante que usted acaba de
señalar
en efecto esto que acabo de señalar lo
encontramos para la mayoría de países
occidentales sin embargo no lo
encontramos en países occidentales como
es el caso de latinoamérica donde las
diferencias en el perfil del voto son
mucho más complejas debido a factores
históricos al sistema político de la
raza o la religión por lo que analizar
los países latinoamericanos es mucho más
complejo dado que la evolución no es
similar entre ellos ni tampoco es
similar al resto de democracias
occidentales hay un elemento de análisis
que ustedes llaman sistema de élite
múltiples me gustaría saber qué
significa esto si se lo puede explicar a
nuestro público y en su caso decirnos si
hay alguno o algunos países de américa
latina que se encuentren en esta
categoría
si nosotros dominamos como el sistema de
elites múltiples es el fenómeno que en
el que documentamos que los más educados
en la actualidad votan a partidos de
izquierda mientras que los individuos de
mayor renta votan en mayor medida a
partidos de derecha esto es un fenómeno
que los años 50 y 40 no existía porque
los menos educados y los individuos de
menos renta votaban más a la izquierda
por lo que lo que observamos es un
proceso de transformación de un sistema
en el que sólo había una única élite los
más educados y los de mayor renta que
votaban a partidos de derecha a un nuevo
sistema de elites múltiples en el que
hay dos élites la élite educativa que
vota en mayor medida a la izquierda y la
élite económica que vota en mayor medida
a partidos de derecha
y en el caso de latinoamérica como hemos
dicho como ya he comentado anteriormente
en casi ninguno de los países observamos
este sistema de líderes múltiples
excepto en el caso mexicano
en el caso mexicano lo que lo que
observamos es que con la caída del pri
surgieron nuevos partidos tanto a la
izquierda como a la derecha a la
izquierda por ejemplo tenemos el caso de
morena y a la derecha tenemos el caso
del pan y lo que observamos es que en la
actualidad las élites educativas votan
en mayor medida a morena mientras que
las élites económicas votan en mayor
medida al pan por lo que también
observamos esa misma ese mismo sistema
de elites múltiples que comentaba en que
observamos en otras democracias
occidentales como es el caso de francia
simplemente para nuestro público el
proyecto el partido revolucionario
institucional morena movimiento de
renovación nacional que es el partido
del actual presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador y el pan partido acción
nacional que el partido que representa
tradicionalmente a la derecha en méxico
una división importante es la división
de clases que aparece a lo largo del
libro que ustedes han preparado sobre
este punto
brasil ser y argentina se diferencian
del resto de los países de américa
latina según el estudio que ustedes
hacen en qué sentido se presenta esta
situación donde hay una fuerte presencia
de la división de clases
si en latinoamérica es una de las
regiones donde documentamos que a
diferencia por ejemplo de lo que vemos
en democracias occidentales donde la
división de clase ha desaparecido en
muchos casos en el caso latinoamericano
en el caso de chile brasil
en el caso de chile y brasil y
argentina- las divisiones de clases son
muy importantes sobre todo se han visto
exacerbadas a lo largo del tiempo en
chile en las últimas las últimas décadas
se han producido una serie de
movilizaciones sociales debido a la
implementación de una serie de políticas
neoliberales que han dado lugar a un
aumento la desigualdad y lo que
observamos es que los menos educados y
los individuos de menor renta han
comenzado a votar en mayor medida a
partidos de izquierda como es el caso de
la concertación excluyendo la democracia
cristiana mientras que los individuos de
mayor renta y de mayor educación votan
más a partidos de derecha como la
democracia cristiano partidos más de
corte conservadora como la democracia
cristiana la renovación nacional esto
mismo lo observamos también en el caso
de brasil en los años 80 el partido de
los trabajadores en brasil aglomeraba un
mayor una mayor parte del electorado de
mayor educación y de mayor renta pero
este partido este partido implementó una
serie de políticas redistributivas que
contribuyeron a mejorar las vidas de los
individuos de menor renta y de mayor
educación y lo que observamos es que en
la actualidad este partido se asocia más
con los
de menor renta y de mayor educación por
lo que han aumentado las divisiones de
clase y en el caso de argentina que es
el otro caso en el que las divisiones de
clase son importantes el caso argentino
es un poco diferente y la gran
diferencia es que el movimiento
peronista surgió como un movimiento de
clase y este movimiento peronista y esta
división de clases sigue siendo
persistente en la actualidad los
individuos de menor renta y de menor
educación siguen votando en mayor medida
a los partidos al partido peronista que
ahora martínez en este trabajo también
hay un elemento que aparece
recurrentemente por lo menos en lo que
se refiere a américa latina y es el tema
de la corrupción un elemento que puede
terminar en algún momento dado un cambio
definitivo en la orientación del voto de
los electores y los seis países que
ustedes analizan pues han estado bañados
de una u otra manera cuando no ahogados
por los temas de la corrupción cómo
juega esta situación en la opción y en
la elección de los electores
esto es un tema muy interesante y un
gran ejemplo un ejemplo muy singular es
el caso de colombia en colombia como
sabemos ha habido un problema bastante
importante con el tema de las farc y la
violencia y esto ha dividido a los
votantes como la violencia se localiza
en zonas rurales donde viven en mayor
medida individuos de rentas bajas y de
menor educación estos individuos para
ellos la importancia de la violencia es
mucho más importante que para los
individuos de mayor educación y mayor
renta que viven en las ciudades para los
que la corrupción es un tema más
importante y lo que lo que se traslada a
esto es que cuando santos empezó a
negociar el proceso de paz con las farc
los individuos de menor renta y de menor
educación que votaban más al partido
uribista se trasladaron y trasladaron su
voto y empezaron a votar
a santos porque para ellos era mucho más
importante el tema de la violencia
cara hay un factor que ha aparecido de
manera relativamente reciente no sólo en
los países occidentales de tradición más
antigua en términos de voto también en
américa latina y es el peso del voto
ecologista llamado voto verde como juega
esto hoy en día en la determinación de
los campos y de los votos en esa región
efectivamente el voto verde se ha visto
ha aumentado con el cambio climático y
con todos los estudios en los que se
muestra que el cambio climático va a
tener efectos no sólo sobre los
individuos pero también sobre la
economía y en los países occidentales lo
que encontramos es que este incremento
de los partidos verdes se asocia con el
voto de individuos de mayor educación en
latinoamérica este proceso ecologista es
aún mucho más embrionario todavía no
tenemos partidos verdes tan importantes
como los que observamos por ejemplo en
el caso de europa pero lo que sí que
estamos observando es que partidos de
corte más progresista están empezando a
introducir el tema del ecologismo de la
economía verde en sus discursos y lo que
esperamos es que los próximos años igual
surjan también algunos partidos que
tengan un gran apoyo y un gran apoyo por
parte seguramente de los más educados en
latinoamérica como vemos en el caso de
europa
una última pregunta si usted me lo
permite hablan también ustedes de las
variables regionales el caso de la
victoria de la actual candidata que
fuera candidato en perú pedro castillo
que logró imponerse con el voto regional
habla precisamente de la importancia de
las regiones en los casos de la votación
en américa latina' si efectivamente el
componente regional es algo bastante
característico del caso latinoamericano
y en particular del caso del caso de
peruano donde la religión está muy
perdona donde la región está muy ligada
también a la raza o la etnia en perú la
zona sur de perú está compuesta por una
mayor proporción de individuos indígenas
votan en mayor medida a partidos donde
el representante es indígena como es el
caso de pedro castillo por lo que vemos
es que hay un gran clivaje en esto entre
regiones donde los individuos del sur
votan en mayor medida a partidos donde
el individuo es indígena como es el caso
de pedro castillo como fue el caso de
holanda humala pues podríamos seguir
desgranando muchas otras variables
realmente hable mente el tiempo se acaba
no me queda sino agradecerle a clara
martínez de toledano profesora del
imperial college co directora del libro
cribas politiken égalité social editado
por la escuela de altos estudios en
ciencias sociales gallimard y 6 su
presencia gracias a ustedes le damos
otra cita aquí la próxima semana en otra
escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]